in eastern ukraine these soldiers are
prepared to defend against any russian
encroachment
and find themselves as tense
as the political standoff
the ultimatum delivered by russia to
nato and the us confirms that they are
not ready for compromise or dialogue
despite repeated assurances from russia
they don't want war
this squadron of soldiers keeps careful
watch
and each has a different theory about
what form a russian attack would take
our navy is not strong enough to
withstand a heavy attack so i think the
coastline could be easily captured
that's my opinion everyone thinks about
a possible invasion through kharkiv or
donbass that's wrong if it's necessary
to attack they'll do it from the sea
the setting may seem tranquil but some
worry if this is just the calm before
the storm
we have hopes for a better future but if
necessary we will fight back
but we really hope there will be no
attack
soldiers tired by the uncertainty but
preparing themselves
for any eventuality
al-jazeera